I guess the answer to that question is
we don't know I agree we really don't
know hey look we agree
huh you guys are the best Halloween is
my favorite holiday and it's coming up
soon what do you guys have any big plans
I don't know just so we could ask this
question I guess no I've never had big
Halloween plans or big holiday plans I
don't really like holidays at all I have
in the past on a few occasions of
Halloween watched a movie called
American World from London I really like
that movie that's a good Halloween movie
to watch yeah that's the one with uh
Christian Bale listening to Huey Lewis
all the time it hit the b square that's
American Werewolf in London dude I don't
think that's yeah it's American
something
um you guys are the best we know what
are your deepest regrets in life
this is [__] relentless